All right so that's supervised learning,
Michael, and
there's a whole bunch of
stuff that we covered.
What about unsupervised learning?
Is there anything there in that section
that you wish we had been
able to talk about, too?
>> It certainly seems
like there ought to be,
in the sense that it was a lot
shorter than the other sections.
>> A lot shorter than
the other sections.
>> Yeah, one thing that I thought would
be worth bringing up in this context is
tf-idf.
So tf-idf is something that
I think is in one version
of this class that you teach.
But we didn't get a chance
to talk about it in here.
And so, what does it have to do
with unsupervised learning, or
randomized optimization?
>> I don't know, Michael.
What does it have to do with it?
>> All right, so tf-idf, it stands for
term frequency inverse
document frequency.
And it is a way of applying
weight when you’re doing,
kind of a nearest neighbor
operation in textual data.
So, if you have a big collection of
text like, web pages and queries,
and you're making queries against
the webpages, you might want to know how
close is this query is to all
the various documents that are in your
collection, all of the various
webpages you might want to return.
And it turns out that there's lots of
different similarity measures that you
can use.
You can use Euclidian distance, you can
use some kind of dot product-y thing.
>> You can use the cosine of
the angle between documents.
>> Yeah there we go.
As a way of measuring how similar
this query is to a document so
we can return the most similar ones.
But it turns out that there's better and
worse ways of doing this waiting.
So it has become apparent
through the years,
I think back into the 60's actually
with Jerry Salton, that a really good
way of doing this that's quite simple
but incredibly powerful, is to say that
the amount of weight that you put on
the appearance of a term in a document,
should be proportional, or positively
related to the term frequency.
The number of times that
word that term appears.
So if I'm searching for things about
snow, and we have a webpage that just
mentions snow in passing,
that's not as important.
As if we have a document that just
mentions snow all over the place.
That the importance of that word grows
with the number of times that it appears
in the document.
>> Well that makes sense, but
then that would imply that probably
the most important word is the.
>> Aye, yes.
Well first of all, no.
It's not really that important.
At least as far as determining
whether some document is relevant.
So, exactly so.
So that's the tf part
is the term frequency.
The idf part,
inverse document frequency, says,
well how many documents in your entire
collection have that word in them?
If it appears indiscriminately
across a large number
of documents then we
want to down-weight it.
>> Like the.
>> Like the, so
the appears almost everywhere.
And so the document frequency,
the number of documents it appears in,
is huge.
The inverse document frequency
is therefore very small,
so that gets very little weight when
you're doing this kind of comparison.
>> That makes sense,
heck did a whole thesis about this.
>> Oh, so
maybe you've heard of this before.
>> I have heard of this before, and
it's actually one of these things
that are just completely accepted.
And it makes sense in the unsupervised
learning case because you're effectively
in the ad hoc retrieval task,
as they call it.
We would probably call it the Google
task if it had been invented.
>> You know what was funny?
I worked in information retrieval
before Google, and what was funny is-
>> They stole all your ideas?
>> No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, Yes.
No it was hard sometimes
writing papers to make
the case that it was important to be
able to do information retrieval.
Like what are we retrieving on?
There's only ten documents in the world.
Like it was a pretty funny thing and
now its so
obvious to everyone
that this is important.
In fact, they don't even think
about it anymore because-
>> It changed the world.
>> It did.
Okay, so
that was something that we
could have talked about,
but mainly we didn't have time and
we were tired.
Let's see, we've talked about semi
supervised learning already, and
that is something that could
have made sense in the section.
And I guess, but that's all sort of
the unsupervised learning space.
Spectral clustering, where as different
kinds of clustering we could've talked
about but, we didn't
>> I like spectral clustering
>> Yeah, it's kind of a neat thing, and
pretty good right, it does pretty
well in the real world, right?
>> Yeah, I think so
>> Okay, so
you should look that up
>> What's neat about it is it actually
doesn't get stuck in local optima.
So it's a whole series of methods that
are based more on linear algebra,
where you can kind of invert
matrixes and get one answer,
than it is on search, and EM, and
gradient decent, and things like that.
>> Yes, there's a claim you could
make that a lot of machine learning,
particularly the unsupervised learning
space, is effectively linear algebra.
At bottom.
>> Well, and spectral clustering,
they fess up to that.
>> Right, anything else we,
we didn't say anything new.
Is there anything in randomized
optimization that we didn't really have
a chance for talking about-
>> I think it's worth at least
mentioning cross entropy,
which is a method that's
really simple to implement.
It's incredibly effective.
Students that I work with have
implemented it in a number of settings,
and it just always does well.
It does better than our
friends simulated and
kneeling and hill climbing and
things like that.
It does really well.
Well, so here's the thing,
I think it's an awful lot like MIMIC.
[CROSSTALK] It's a MIMIC mimic.
Yeah, very nice.
But it seems to me that the two
communities weren't really
aware of each other.
So maybe we need to put
these two things together.
You can be MIMIC, and
I can be cross-entropy and we can figure
out how they relate to each other.
>> And
we can cross fertilize each other.
I don't like the sound of that at all.
>> [LAUGHTER] Okay, so on that note,
we'll leave unsupervised learning and
randomized optimization.
>> Yes, see and this is what
happens when we're not supervised.
>> [LAUGHTER] Well done.